it is week five of google cloud next on
air
and this week we're focusing on data
analytics i'm roger martinez and welcome
to this week in cloud
where we're taking a sneak peek at this
week's content
week five is all about data analytics
meaning we want to help you make the
most of your data by helping you
efficiently store
and get insights from it we've got
sessions on everything from storing and
streaming your data
to empowering it with real time ai
bigquery ml
and more it's always exciting to hear
real world examples of how people build
on google cloud
don't sweat the big stuff is a perfect
example
geotab talks about how they use bigquery
and lots of other tools to enable their
data science team to analyze petabytes
of data
the key here is to let them focus on the
data and models while letting google's
infrastructure
handle all the heavy lifting now i love
to stay on top of new updates that make
google cloud tools
easier to use so my pick for the week is
awesome new features to help you manage
bigquery
there's lots of great ways in the cloud
to help you wrangle your data
but bigquery really shines this week
this talk is perfect for newcomers and
power users alike with practical ways to
get your head around pricing
administration and monitoring to round
out the week
make sure to check out the cool demos
that show what data analytics can help
you do
this week features some great videos and
a cool interactive demo that visualizes
mlb picture data in a 3d environment
whether you're a sports fan
a statistics expert or just like playing
around with interactive demos
be sure to take a look to add these
sessions to your digital playlist
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment
or tweet us using the hashtag google
cloud next
we'll see you in the cloud